your east coast connection for packaging
and processing delivers all the business
solutions you need in one convenient
place
pac expo east is back in philadelphia
march 21st through the 23rd connect in
person with more than 400 exhibitors see
technology in action in a way that can't
be conveyed online
and delve into the trends transforming
our industry from the latest in robotics
and automation to sustainable and new
materials and so much more
talk directly with suppliers and explore
solutions for life sciences
food and beverage
cannabis
cosmetics
pet food
and more
learn how to operate more efficiently
during free educational sessions and
product demonstrations right on the show
floor
and throughout the event socialize and
strengthen your network at events hosted
by industry influencers
everything you need to spark innovation
is happening here in one convenient
place where your entire team can attend
don't miss pack expo east register today